also 80 begonnen super-g er ist nämlich
vorbeigekommen beim warum ich du bist
hier in der gegend gewesen als in köln
ich war heute bei der chronik auto
gestern besuchten fifa 13
ich darf sich sein aber exklusiv vor der
presse zocken war präsent
also vor der presse bevor die presse ist
schon gar die das ständig vor der presse
soll wieder steht die pressewelt
irgendwo und ja es natürlich cool erst
mal sowas überhaupt machen so wird das
war es das erste mal in deutschland auch
es waren leute bei big brother zwar die
jungs von pi zwei drei leute im sommer
festival leute da das hat einfach spaß
gemacht ihm einfach schön gemütlich
gezockt die banken das war hier in der
zweiten liga ok tisch es trifft sich
dass er gleich nach hause fahren
ok jetzt kriegt ihr sowas exklusiv es
gab jetzt bei der fifa so ein kleiner
skandal mit samsung die haben blogger
versucht vor den karren zu spannen
sie haben ihr ziel setzen gegen gewalt
die geräte den kunden demonstriert wir
haben ja zum teil kommen ja der firma
auch an zu die wollen irgendwas ist ja
schon mal passiert dass die versucht
haben einen sofort haben zustand also
filmen sind jetzt schon an mich
herangetreten nachdem organisierten
anrufbeantworter gesprochen
irgendwie hat er meine videos zu hoffen
vater kann man einmal die stimme gefällt
ich würde jetzt gerne mit dem
versprechen das war mit insgesamt 35
aber dass man so sein dann hat ja echt
versucht einen als vom montag zu
engagieren
aber es wird auch immer mehr in die
rennen gehen also dass die leute erst
mal sehen was wir für ich sag mal
werbeflächen aber muss man aufpassen
sich halt nicht unter preis zu verhelfen
würde ich das machen viele moment weil
es ist arbeit das darf man nicht
vergessen und die meisten leute wissen
einfach gar nicht was ist zum beispiel
facebook wird also wenn man mal gucken
kann
beispiel gebrauchte aufrufe kaufen bei
youtube man zahlt wie viel zeit ich weiß
vielleicht ist es glaube ich haben sich
billig das problem ist aber glaube ich
dann wenn man dann in die auswertung
unter den videos guckt dann sind die
views alle aus
das funktioniert auf jeden fall
und da sieht es bei mir so was würdet
ihr gern richtig verkauft ein echter
wien ist noch mehr wäre ein echter
abonnenten und dafür spezielle werbung
das damals im youtube hat taxiert ein
abonnent um den zu bekommen also wenn
man ja mal geld dafür ausgeben würde um
mit werbung oder diversen aktionen
irgendwie nach und entwicklung bis dahin
wert von 6 dollar
kann sein ja
dazu muss man sagen dass ich was wir
hier machen es gibt ja mal wieder im
vorfeld geldgeil nein das ist genau das
ging ja auch nicht so schwül und sagt
ich wünsche abschluss war weil ich
möchte die öffentlichkeit job der welt
am und apl vorkommen dass er mit seinem
job geld von die machen wir haben das
glück dass wir mit unserem hobby geld
bach genannt und ich habe es damals
schon als sich basketball gespielt habe
damit verdient oder als ich das was ich
auf der liga war okay ist weiß ich so
viel geld
ich rate ja auch jedem macht dein hobby
zum beruf also finde letztlich deine
leidenschaft genau und das musst du als
beruf machen das kann ja was weiß ich da
eine hat als leidenschaft mit holz zu
arbeiten der nächste jetzt kommt zb der
eine spielt gerne sieht man sagt ja ich
will
prof das ist natürlich auch wenn der
talentierte problembereich trainer aber
ich glaube aber es ist auch komisch wenn
man leidenschaft etwas empfinden was man
nicht kann das ein bisschen komisch wenn
man sich also selber vollständig würde
super gut singen können wie sting auf
total gerne aus der scheiße an dinge es
hat ja nicht so scheiße an aber nicht so
gut geht will
das ist auf dem wir manche sachen kann
man zum hobby machen man muss nicht so
ganz sicher kann und manche sachen
sollte man zum beruf machen kann
so jetzt würde ich sagen sind die fragen
eröffnet haben das hier so gemacht ihr
nebenan sitzen benny der guckt auf
facebook twitter und so weiter und so
fort und holt eure kommentare raus ich
guck dir auch oft da habe ich hier neben
dran und wir gucken natürlich auch auf
die kommentare auf die zuschauer wir
haben warum 912 das rind die ruft
zuschauer nehmen da find die zuschauer
glaube ich dass auch wir können wir mal
gucken auch auf youtube glaube ich wenn
die kannst du mal gucken auf youtube da
sind die realen zuschauerzahlen
wir sind immer bei 123 zuschauer ok 193
als stimmt es doch der 130 gibt langsam
wo finde ich das auf youtube eigentlich
das findest du jetzt auswahl jetzt ein
youtube kanal wo kann man das zum kanal
wieder erfahren dass ich man muss unter
jockey okay also und david zu sehen wir
sagte regel abgeschafft
das ist aber es geht langsam das ist
lustig also beim letzten mal ist das
erste mal mitteln abends hatte ich dann
aber so eine diskussion auf facebook und
twitter entstanden zum thema video day
und hab ich gesagt so jetzt muss ich ihm
also länger auf machen und alle fragen
beantworten es gibt und da hat man so
knapp 500 es geht auch langsam hoch ich
weiß auch nicht jeder mit dem
veröffentlichen ist wann das
veröffentlicht wird offensichtlich ist
es waren wir wieder mit diesem ist auf
youtube zu tun dass die veröffentlichung
sehr langsam läuft jetzt geht im moment
die zahlen nämlich nach ober seemer 250
danny die zuschauer wieder die zuschauer
sind 213 ja das 17 krone aus wir haben
hier 222 insulins ein bisschen hinterher
ok also wir sind offen für eure fragen
lassen schon mal was drüber wachsen
okay wir haben das er lässt darüber
wachsen wir können hier auch gucken
heute mal so da sind durch die das jetzt
einfach frisch sagen januar 2009
klassiker magst du bratwurst
das ist kommt die frage über die apostel
ich weiß noch nicht wie es ist das
genauso hansa bei dem spruch sag ich mal
das ist irgendwie glaub ich hab das
damals zu tun dass diejenigen einfach
keine gescheite folge ein feld also
nachfolger mario draghi irgendwann mal
die frage ist das ja immer auch
dokumentieren dann dem muss jetzt ein
name wird nicht ein einziges
fertigkeiten ich kaum aussprechen
und wenn ich zum grill gehe ich nehme
die lieber ein stück bratwurst angst ein
stück fleisch mischung also es kommt auf
das fleisch liebe person summe also
magath resources on stage winners dass
das habe ich wirklich gern von bisons
super einstieg soll auch dieser hatte im
vorteil was wenig kalorien residieren
ich sehe jetzt nicht sage nichts oder
nicht ist es auch verdammt teuer wäre
schmeckt super zeit mit vater als rind
und wesentlich zahlt nur wenn du so ich
sag jetzt mal sommer gehört nimmt isst
du merkst es machen ja es war dieser um
es einfach nur geil sagt und ok körper
nachwuchssport reimers und kleine
kulinarische empfehlungen von comma
gedauert
bison steak jetzt gehen wir langsam hier
auf die 300 zuschauer also es läppert
sich langsam und ich warte auf die
nächste frage was mit den wählen dass
ich habe auch schon rausgeschickt komme
ich hier kommt nichts an ist er super
an et fir auch wir haben wir sitzen mich
hier einen schnitt rechner mit edit 4ad
momente - media.de
jetzt habe ich gesagt das natürlich
super und schicken mich ziemlich alles
gerüstet so rolfes ich habe noch nichts
bekommen bisher ist auch keine mail
angekommen
das thema abgeschickt ich hab geschickt
auf den knopf gedrückt
hier kommt nichts versorgt kommt nichts
naja ganz muss ich hiermit wieder
aufmachen um sonst was
dann gibt es eine akustische hier
hier kommt nichts auf stoff twitter.com
nicht sonst kommt gerne was vielleicht
noch auf twitter
und wir haben jetzt hier von mysms
keppeln commander glaubst du wirst du
mit youtube geld verdienen und wie würde
es ansonsten weiter gehen also noch ich
wiederhole markt kommen alle von vista
user apple die frage an commander
krieger wie lange bleibst du kannst du
noch mit youtube geld verdienen
überlegen es weiter
und wie würde es sonst weiter grund wie
würde es sonst weiter
also ich glaube mit youtube wie gesagt
ich glaube wir sind noch am anfang
erstmal was noch kommen wird
ich glaube sogar man noch gemütlich 3 14
jahren locker und selbst wenn ich keinen
bock mehr darauf habe findet sich
sicherlich irgend eine andere
möglichkeit sei dass ich in gaming shop
auf machen sowas unterrichtung irgendwas
im jahr kann und weise selber noch nicht
ich hätte niemals
ich habe eine lustige geschichte dazu
ich habe vor ein paar tagen flippte wo
die moral getroffen
eine länge von maschine und der dir
erzählt die geschichte ach ja als wir
angefangen hatten wir dann irgendwann 50
millionen 15 monate haben alle gesagt
jetzt schickt jetzt habt ihr eure
glasdecke kommen die 100 mio jetzt aber
wirklich mehr kriegt irgendwo mehr gehen
eine milliarde jetzt aber möglich mehr
gibt zwei milliarden sind sie zwischen
wird ich glaube auch ich bin überzeugt
davon
viele sehen ja und das ist hat youtube
auf die rolle ist etwas ganz besonderes
es gibt die community funktion es gibt
kommentare und so weiter und so fort mit
dem wir jetzt auch intensiver arbeiten
jetzt 300 zuschauer intensiv arbeiten
aber es hat noch was anders ist ist
nämlich ein neuer verwaltungsweg wie
astra wie kabel terrestrisches fernsehen
und da sind wir noch so dermaßen am
anfang wenn man das verkleinerte
komplett verlieren das macht was werden
schon installiert er müsste sich
überhaupt direkt am fernseher eigenen
account erstellen und da wird es von
deren profite und boni zahlen
es ist für mich noch kein ende in sicht
auch noch mal so natürlich noch ein
bisschen ertragen gut ich bin auch ich
bin ich bin davon überzeugt dass es ohne
essen geht um die mails an
übrigens jetzt kommt ihm jetzt anders
funktioniert ich bin also wirklich davon
überzeugt dass das noch dass wir ganz am
anfang stehen und vor allem dass da eine
komplette neuentwicklung das neue format
endlich meine letzte
wer hätte vor fünf jahren gedacht dass
irgendwann mal leute auf youtube spiele
kommentieren und diese videos millionen
das ist nicht das ist das ist das finde
ich und du kannst du nicht wirken und
auch entspannt oder machst du dir jeden
monat sorgen ob das noch funktioniert
dann mache ich mir keine darüber weil
ich weiss genau in binz von heute auf
morgen ändern und das kann das
letztendlich ein wenn main kanal gehackt
wird
doch dann habe ich ein riesiges problem
womit haben sie fast 43 zeichen als beim
pastor mit einem möglichen zahlen
buchstaben ist ok und in gewünschter
rechnet man hier oben reicht dann eine
weile lang durch ist nur dass und ja
wenn man kann ein weg wäre und ich hätte
keinen bock mehr darauf an was man
daraus lernen
ich kann dich aber beruhigen youtube
kann gelöschte kanäle herstellen ja dann
sagst du sein pressesprecher von den
banken lässt ja aber ich habe ja langsam
einem 180 ps gelöscht das war schon ein
richtiger schlag da bin ich dann
ich habe mal überweise das war noch im
alten system ja da habe ich aus versehen
anstatt ein video alle videos auf der
seite markiert das waren 80 stück und in
hoher auflösung kann und ich bin so ein
typ auch wenn ich irgendwas von desktop
gleichstellung entfernt und direkt
dahinter gewinnen das ist direkt
bestellt sieht ganz so aus ich gucke da
nicht hin willst du wirklich 80 videos
sowie ein liga spiel zurück ich ja hier
und dann auf einmal gewesen
das war durch schon auf das misst das
war richtig dabei noch nicht wussten da
war keine gute laune
kein wunder das ist eine schlechte lang
hast
dann sollte man mich nicht ansprechen
ich halte dann meistens die fresse und
wieso die ganze zeit habe ich welche
miese laune habe mich recht ruhig so ist
denn so ich bin ich dann alleine bitte
und dann brauche ich zu meinen leuten
einen ruhepunkt so etwas wie sie ihn
rein
die welt stehe okay wir hätten sonst
alleine vorne rennt ist super ich würde
am rhein
also jetzt kommen wieder keine mails an
wir brauchen neue kommentare benny okay
findet es deine familie oder deine
freunde dass du in youtube-videos machst
und wie stehen sie dazu
updates verstanden also wie finden
freunde familie und so weiter
dass er videos auf youtube macht und wie
stand es also meine familie informieren
das möchte ich nicht aussprechen also
okay ein und sprechen sender mehr also
meine meine familie hat eigentlich groß
gar keinen bezug zum internet
ausgelernte die auch auf der gamescom
mit dabei haben sich einfach mal so ein
bisschen eindruck davon zu machen wie
das ganze aussieht und als jan gesehen
hat da ist mein rad und mein neffe
unterschreibt da irgendwelche iphones
und ipads alles die war schon die sachen
flash hätte sich das so nicht
vorgestellt
mein vater kam mit den materialien
überhaupt nicht anfang genauso wenig wie
mehr gehabt hat so ein bisschen versucht
zu erklären mut ist und ich so gut bin
viel spaß macht versucht meine freunde
finden
ja also ich habe von keinem irgendwo ein
mieses feedback einzigen höre es ist
krass du verdienst damit so viel geld
und ich muss ja arbeiten und das alles
machen dann verdient so deine kohle das
schon so ein bisschen der neid ländern
ausfällt aber auch dass jetzt keiner
irgendwie sagt er also es totales rätsel
dar wobei es gibt etwa aspekte du machst
das was dir spaß macht aber man kann ja
nicht sein dass das jetzt ein moment wo
man die kundengruppe erschien mir
definitiv nicht auch ja jetzt einfach
mal zu sagen ja ich komme jetzt nach
können setzt mich hierher
natürlich sieht es für euch dann auch
noch nie ich verdiene jetzt
keine kohle aber die arbeit hinter den
kulissen die sehen die leute nicht und
das ist das krasse der und also es ist
nicht einfach mal so ich habe youtube
kanal ich spiele jetzt mal ein bisschen
und ganzen tag so ist es wirklich nicht
also sage ich meistens ich kann es
michael sagen du kommst nach hause dass
es nicht früh oder bist du kommst sehr
spät ins bett und stets meistens sehr
früh auf ein an sich viel zu tun ist wir
arbeiten
ich mache das noch mit wandern bauer und
30 fragen dann wieder gut noch mehr also
das sehe ich auch bei vielen kanälen
dass es irgendwann mit vanessa ein paar
mehr geht also nicht weil ich kann mich
selber nicht vermindern würde für sie
nicht zu machen
aber bei vielen sich das auch so dass es
als ein mensch irgendwann nicht mehr zu
machen
hier geht die puste aus weil es so ein
bisschen mehr
die hab ich bock drauf also da habe ich
schon lust drauf mit mikrofon kann man
dem ganzen es unsichtbar
was die leute ja gar nicht sehen
vielleicht zeigt wie das genau aussieht
also erweitert ihr seht auch immer das
nette die aussagen wie sie in christoph
wenn man dann auf dem video center aus
einer wand wo alles drauf also die ganze
hintergrund oder so bezieht man gar
nicht immer sehr vieles aufgebaut ist
das alles hier jetzt strom ist das ist
nicht bei ihm der deckenlampe karriere
derzeit wie trainer kurz also hier sitzt
wenn ihr jetzt zum beispiel der fall
dass ihr technisch alles eingerichtet
hat hier kommen wir jetzt mal hin das
ist die eine lampe und kann man und da
ist die anderen anwälte haben jetzt nur
von innen aber kein licht tritt
normalerweise machen damit seine kante
haben
und weil ich war den ganzen tag
unterwegs ich konnte das letztlich hätte
sich einrichten können
ich habe das einmal gemacht bei ich weiß
gar nicht mehr wer eine promi und habe
mit aufgebaut
ich war komplett verschwiegen es war
eine katastrophe
es gibt es probleme
unsere klingel und zwar haben wir die
tür offen legen wenn man nicht schreiben
wenn man durch geht man auch diese
diesel ich glaube ich lieber eine
richtig heiß die das sind die details
werden jetzt hier noch gemütlich doch es
geht ja das müsste auch ein steht aber
das sind schon acht radler die werden
manchmal wenn es richtig heiß draußen
ist ist es zur sache vergessen
also es gibt der led lang mal so kalt
nicht nur diese phase jetzt also man
kann ja sehr preiswert inzwischen lampen
bekommen
die haben ein paar kleine nachteile von
diesen so viel preis selber kaufen kann
für ein paar tausend euro
das eigentlich geht sieht man auch nicht
was ihr kommen zur nächsten frage wann
hast du angefangen shooter zu spielen
fragt diese fukushima fallout der kann
also ich habe 25 spielen vor knapp drei
jahren
und das kann das bei uns im talk oder
fangen wir erzählten des kam durch
casino kollegen gesagt was ich dass es
nämlich auch das problem den du dann um
23 24
ansonsten aber ist da kannst du dich ins
bett gehört also dass das ist bei mir
auch so der punkt wäre weiß leute fragen
mich kann ich dich enden können wir
zusammen zocken oder so ich zocke
meistens ehrlich gesagt nachts
erstens weil dann haben meine kollegen
aus dem casino feierabend mit dem ich
gerne noch um das waren einfach spaß und
ich nutze das zocken auch zum abschalten
ja so da wenn ich weiß okay ich habe
jetzt gameplay gameplay not muss ich
auch über tag starten
was mir dann die zeit der aufführung
eines projekte und alle arbeit und
ansonsten weiß wo ich tagsüber auch
meine normale arbeit mache und ab geht's
dann zum zocken und da sind die meisten
als im westen
das stimmt viele davon wenn unsere
zuschauer oft auch schon genau die und
das ist auch richtig so
das ist richtig so das relief mit roman
dazu trocken
das habe ich auch wm
wenn man kommt mein reicht jedenfalls
nicht vormittags
also ich gehe meistens zum 10
also ich muss leider vorher nochmal eins
sein wenn es jetzt endlich richtig also
ich es gab tage da war ich um neue songs
ins bett und bin demokrat wieder auf dem
weiter geht's mehr als man denkt dass
das muss doch mal um dieses dann machen
wir
du sagst das liegt momentan mit wenig
schlaf auszukommen
also dass ich kenne das training welches
drängen die macht man es also das kommt
daher weil du matin chips oder woher man
muss ja nicht sein aber du musst ja
vorstellen was dein körper wozu passt
ein körper im grunde zustandes zu
leisten das habe ich bisher ja immer
dass ich so kleine punkte also keine
ausnahme portion und dann kann ich so
viel da mithalten und das alter nur
wilden warum das ist genau wie wenn du
läufst du läufst von hier bis der körper
lag ich hab keinen bock dann merkst du
schon so okay bin ich kaputt bin ich
fertig lorenz normalen blogs und dann
sagt der körper nichts geht jetzt gerne
mehr bist du bist fertig dich hin ja wie
viel prozent hast du verbrauch 8 prozent
von einem gesamt heißt wenn du da über
diese grenze hinweg ist das ding da
immer häufiger noch mal aber auf dauer
hier werden bassist und weniger würde
das notwendige tun will einfach nicht
der in seiner scheune und spannung dem
muss angerufen festgeschehen man muss es
auch manchmal mit tricks machen ja
einfach nur der will muss starken erst
im moment hängt also stark genug
ich habe einen super ich habe ja bei mir
war er herausfand ich wollte unbedingt
abnehmen und dann ein trick war ich habe
mir gesagt das ist für deinen beruf
es gehört geht's zu deinem beruf dazu
das zu machen
ok also ich hab meine ich fühle mich
hier
du darfst nicht abnehmen es geht nicht
es gehört ja das ist so
also ich muss sagen es kommt immer mal
wieder vor ort hätte erstens damit
treffe mich nicht weil ich fühl dich
wohl so geblieben und das ist was ich
meinem leben erreicht habe dass das muss
man erst mal hinkriegen absolut jahren
sogar und auch das wie ich damals mal
aussah ich hatte mich immer mein
schätzchen ich hatte damals 153 kilo
erwartet ich war damals muskelpaket
diese leute sind immer gern ein foto
gesehen dass das auch so richtige
schnäppchen grad
das heißt man wie espenlaub wenn man sie
schon auf der straße begegnete also ich
sag mal so nein ich bin ich bin ja das
richtig ist persönlichen aber da sieht
man ja nicht von 43 gegenüber ordentlich
trainiert so ist und warum machst es
nicht mehr mein ganzes leben damals war
nur für die ernährung für den job und
ich will mein leben genießen lässt sich
ambulanzen für die nach motto jetzt
klingelt der wecker jetzt muss ich bei
30 jetzt muss ich meine afrika stunden
lagen
ich hatte im kompletten essensplan ruhig
fünf bis sechs mal zeit bevor
und nur solche sachen ja so oder so was
mal aber trotzdem davon dass ich jetzt
nicht so möglich ist ja du sagst du
sagst du sahel warum sollte ich mich
sowas aussetzen ich fühle mich so wie
ich finde ich war trotzdem meinen sport
und wie lange hast du das gemacht
personenschützer und danach hast du da
hatten war es im moment oder sagte jetzt
will ich das ist irgendwie
lebensfeindlich oder ich hab keinen
genießen ich war damals die verletzung
gesprochen und das land auch noch
richtig also schon ist das wird auch
noch der lange schon im fuß nicht
bräuchte zeigen
keiner
und anderthalb jahre krankenhaus gedreht
an buchung an
und dann kam halt so wenn die erste wahl
die muskeln abgebaut klar wenn du nicht
die kranken aus ernährung sie ja und
wenn du vorher die ganze zeit wirklich
60 jahren und nur deine ernährung hat
das wieder auf einmal der uni damit denn
brands an spaghetti bolognese folie weil
sich frittiert wohnen sind zeugnisse
direkt am tisch zu und dann irgendwie
danach habe ich festgestellt ob geben
für personenschutz müsste ich viel
zuviel wieder trainieren wieder auf das
level erspart was oft maßlos das heißt
sie der kamera sondern vielleicht hatte
ich quasi aus dem beruf ausüben also die
verletzung ja und die arbeiter verletzt
anderthalb monate also heute mit
krankenhaus 6 op s das ist mir dann das
ist jetzt mal danach passierten obere
unter sprunggelenksfraktur mit
abschalten auseinandersetzung das im
beruf im beruf und wer meinen kompletten
fuß zersplittert für sie war das hier in
europa oder war das alles war in
deutschland in deutschland werden
deutschland hat dachte darüber reden in
welchem bereich das war in berlin
deutschland hat nicht nur schön es gibt
auch in deutschland immer fairen und das
damit hat es so kontakt aber wie weit
kannst darüber erzählen denn ich möchte
dabei der hinweis dass das ist für mich
ein bereich ich habe noch nicht
abgeschlossen doch richtig trauert da
auch nicht mehr her ich habe jetzt mein
ding mit dem ausruf ich bin es war nur
damals ein komplett anderes sehen was
für damit menschen so gemacht die wir
kennen auch also vom personenschutz gab
aber vorfall als türsteher du hattest
teilweise mit gangs bandidos hells
angels dann mit albanischer mafia mit
typisch russische mafia die waren jede
woche war die auf der tagesordnung
und nicht immer nur weil ja wie geht's
herr krieger als sn gut sondern ganz
normal die 100
gespräche und schweizer und hat man sehr
gut geschlafen
ich habe sehr gut geschlafen weil das 1
6 kilo
machst du auch nicht viel denn da bin
ich sagt dass man ostern davon entstehen
weil die haben keine skrupel dich
absolut zug dann die haben überhaupt
kein problem
das ist ebenso scheißegal und wenn die
da geht es gar nicht um also das ist
wirklich ist eine wirkliche unterhält
die wir die wir haben die meisten leute
auch so gar nicht sehen und ich sage ich
will auch nicht gesehen werden das war
so wie es ist das ist auch im käse aber
gucken wir auch bewusst weg oder sollten
einkommen wir können nicht mehr
hingucken dafür zu schön um ein bandidos
und hells angels hat er jetzt gerade
ohne ende hingeguckt nein nichts da wird
nur an die oberfläche also da steckt
wesentlich mehr ändern hätten wir vorher
erhängen müssen was heißt hingucken
müssen also ich kenne geschichten da
sind jetzt viele jahre ich glaube ich
darf darüber reden da sind programmchefs
von fernsehsendern vor der einige
planten ausstrahlung würde dieses
themengebiet fotos ihrer familie
zugeschickt worden und dann sind diese
fanden diese fessel nicht vorstellen so
jetzt haben wieder einen boss proben und
machen den medien müssten
aufklärungsarbeiten die oberfläche das
ist so das so sind die karte wenn jedes
unternehmen so arbeiten würde wg in
deutschland gar keine probleme weil sie
so perfekt organisiert saniert das ist
wirklich wahnsinn aber mit angst und
schrecken oder was ist passiert
nein überhaupt nicht sondern wagen auf
es gibt auch vernünftige also hast dich
nur worauf wirklich auf die fresse so
nach motto nein also es wird auch
wirklich sehr viel gesprochen
natürlich ist die eine oder andere
drogen auch mit dabei aber es wird schon
vernünftig mit ihr gesprochen
du wirst auch als mensch das becken egal
woher wir kommen jetzt mit irgendeiner
mafia im monat zu tun hast da ist nicht
egal wer du bist deutscher sowie halten
klischees du bist rechts gewissen du
bist ihr eine person durch diese
position und ich möchte dass du das noch
knallharte arbeit cross jetzt mit mich
interessieren oder realität national
sondern kleinen drogenboss und zum
schluss dominierten 16-jährigen müssen
toller film erste filme kosten haben wir
gucken mal in die mails wir also ich
möchte auch schon mal bitte dazu dem
thema möchte ich keine seite entfernt
worden sei das was hier noch nicht so
aber das ist ein punkt
ich bin durch sehr viel scheiße damals
gelaufen
der ist einfach hinter mir okay aber
letztlich unerwartet da von dingen die
man lebt egal was sie sind gehören
hierzu biografie die höheren energie zu
man kann sich action definitiv nicht
definitiv nicht ich bin auch froh dass
ich sag auch kein blut an meine ender
belassen
ich kenne viele leute an meiner position
die vorbestraft sind schwerer körper
hält als ich hab gar nichts und da denke
ich wirklich es ja auch immer so das was
man heute ist ist man ja nur deswegen
weil man vorher das erlebt was also wenn
damals nicht so passiert erhältlich hier
zum beispiel gut andere fragen mit
commander hast du ein auto wenn ja
welches auto fährst du fakt patina wie
heiß es nie patina die partie
ich habe einen seat leon 2.0 tdi in
schwarz das hört sich flotter ist nicht
gefährdet
3 100 210 doch nicht so flott doch so
ungefähr
okay okay okay es gibt also stets auf
das amerikanische leben als ist eine
internetadresse klose mein leben durch
lustige deutsche markt an was wollte ich
sagen es gibt jetzt ein bmw der ist auf
250 april die anderen
du kannst aber für 2500 euro und
fahrradtraining machen
danach wird er auf 300 tage scheint das
finde ich auch gut so ich habe auf
sicherheitsthemen und so alles machen
müssen
ich finde es wirklich gut dass sie so
machen wir sollten ja 200 menschen
also ich bin nach einer wir haben dass
das ist auch mal was weise antwort ich
habe mein video ich auch noch voller
freiheit nicht mehr schön oder nachts
man ja aber ich muss sagen ich habe es
gelernt
ich kann mit dem knie op herrlichen
wagen halten ok und auch wenn der reifen
platzen sollte
wobei man sagen muss heutzutage die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass reich platz ist
bei 0 2 schon mal ein kontaktnetz der
platz ja nicht richtig das macht mut
und ja es wird jetzt nach rechts gezogen
und muss gegen linke und sorgte der
platz langsam luft gemessen so ganz
gemütlich an fahrt sowas ist sehr
unwahrscheinlich also weshalb ich weiß
was ich mache hast du nicht angst ich
meine es gibt ja ab 10 polizei guckt
sich videos an könnte gerne machen
also ganz ehrlich ich weiß es steht
nirgendwo verboten dass ich bei den am
lenker rahmen muss echt wichtig dann
theoretisch muss gleiches § 1 weist man
darf niemanden blablabla also ich kann
ja was weiß ich das ist der möchte zum
beispiel nächste ich mache aus reflex so
der platz in dem moment was also aber
ich sage wenn ich niese sage ich meinen
beitrag beachten rollstuhl ist wirklich
wenn du dann ist so eine sekunde und
setzten eine sekunde
hast du ein paar projekte die du in den
nächsten monaten raushauen das fragt
robin dutt 20 11 deutlich also das
nächste große projekt was frauen
ok ich weiß noch nicht wer noch 200
mitarbeiter die welche man noch nicht
nennen
dazu wären zwar werde ich versuchen
richtig attraktive sexy darin zu
organisieren okay das ganze dann
anzünden sollte so ein projekt in china
gut dann haben wir hier
hey commander wahrheit nie bestätigt hat
youtube daneben sehr verändert und
inwiefern drei duelle sagt drei hatten
wir einen schon
das hat mein leben stark verändert und
man muss sie einfach mal vorstellen wir
mal einkaufen geht und da zu sein das
ist schon so so krass
gar 200 also ich musste irgendwie ist
das für dich wenn das passiert wenn die
leute ansprechen
ich sag mal so ist gibt natürlich
momente wo man sagt welz gern allein
aber das problem ist ich kann einfach
nichts ändern
abonnenten sagen weiß was er ziel einer
weil ich es am main abonnenten hätte
mich gerne mehr und er war vielleicht
bei der gamescom overland treffen und
sieht mich zur straße und der ist
einfach mal vier wochen sollen dafür
strafen kommt etwas tun was ich sagen
kann es ist doch schließlich einfach auf
euch zusammen
das stimmt das muss man so sagen
wir haben weitere fragen und zwar ca
sie haben eine satzung ja da ich mich an
rackert rasch auch kind also andré
krigar aber ca
berlin zu außerhalb von youtube geld
hast einen jobgipfel frage ob china
ziehen in die gene tag verdienen
natürlich habe ich mir eure sachen wie
ihre homepage livestream youtube an
sicher mehrere sachen wieder laufen
aber ansonsten einen anderen job aus der
youtube habe ich nicht ist das auch im
volk möglich es ist ja gabriele strouhal
sage nach sind es schwer zu sagen es
wirklich willst du hast mein baby vier
vorgearbeitet hat dann kann man sich ein
bisschen zurücknehmen aber momentan bin
ich
darum vor ausmachen was dann fragt 1015
rudi interessiert dich bundesliga bist
du ein fußball fans ja stimmt das hat
man ja jetzt nicht starke spiegel
großartigen der fach und ich muss mal
wirklich was zeigen jetzt ich habe ja
eigentlich gar nicht sagen ich darf
nicht zeige derzeit als treff ist so
genial ich dass das zeug habe auf jeden
fall
fussball ich habe überlegt mir den
dauerkarte zu holen aber da der
livestream bin ich dann mache auch gerne
mal da ist bin ich und zwar das ist von
fifa da wollte ich ersten reaktion
sarrazin gegen fortuna düsseldorf
spielen und hier siehst du die bewertung
von ersten fc köln da steht ja nichts
ich meine verstehen urlaube da steht
nicht nur 0 und kann man das lernen wie
so sehen
ja das kann man sehen also hier nicht da
das ist fortuna düsseldorf und da ist
quellen
polen hat keine bewertung 000
bildschirme 000
das war schon ziemlich witzig so machen
ja jetzt sieht man ja nix gesehen dass
ich bin ich gar nicht zeigen
aber das war natürlich ziemlich kugel na
ja aber was glaubst du
wenn wir zwei liga bestehen und wird in
die dritte geben ich glaube ja auch wenn
ich es euch wirklich dich gerne zweiter
reicht ich fürchte dass ihre reingehen
es ist eine katastrophe
es ist einfach eine katastrophe wenn wir
schon jemand hatte im vorstand der
spinner ist jetzt da kommen sie sehen
sie diesen kalauer das liegt ja nicht
hinten ist auch frisiertisch
muskelstärke werden
meinst du dich auf der domplatte es ist
sie waren einfach nicht vorbereitet auf
die zeiten lieber komplett nicht ich hab
dann auf einer der fc spieler der jungen
fc spieler war mein nachbar gut und die
haben ernsthaft gesagt ja und dann
planen damit man zum beispiel und der
vater dann habe ich dann auf der
startseite mit dem markt keiner geredet
der fed jetzt das geld war weg niemals
geplant mit dem ball an heimlichen
gesprochen analog ja selber schuld also
und ihrem eine fortuna spielt hat er
zwei starke spiele beliefert und köln
aufwuchs schönes 20 gern in rivalen
gladbach die oft nicht gerade zu
unterschätzen sind 0 0
vielleicht noch nicht aber durch eine
große auswahl wird damit auch ein dorf
darf eine gute fußballmannschaft haben
david spinner landeshauptstadt
das ist wirklich das abkommen ist machen
wir alles ganz deprimiert patti labelle
ich muss immer kompatibel sehr gut so
sieht es also aus wenn dich in dieser
kleinen schuss das lesen wobei ich
könnte es ja einfach größer machen das
ist ja jetzt er praktisch nicht
commander ich will dein praktikant sein
fakt partie bestimmt sein commander
frage also momentan ist noch gar nicht
geplant und ich glaube wenn ich einen
fabrikanten annehmen würde
doch die würden sich zum prügeln und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich glaube nicht
dass er von anfang an werden würde weil
ich bin ein ziemlicher pingel
sklaventreiber sklaventreiber nicht also
ist er zu aber hart okay gut
benny visier ja wunderbar danke ja
wunderbar der gesagt es ist wirklich
schön
nein ich glaube auch das macht auf dauer
spaß also das muss man sagen eben
unabhängig von allem was spaß aber es
ist weniger arbeit und wir nur spaß
haben will
er ist dem westen schaffen so fußball
hat allerdings käme vergessen fragt
pixel hunter 1 hast du schon als mit
natürlich nicht doch keiner fing an und
sagt über 200.000 gedauert vom anfang
bis zum erfolg ist keine hallo ich bin
ja immer noch im wachstum
daher große ersten moment war wurde das
zweite hat schon echt weiterhin klar auf
rufe ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie viel
ich halte das waren 40 auf oder so was
soll ich schon fast das nicht richtig
meine birne meinen dann bist du musst
dir vorstellen wir machen damals 88
leute haben ihre spiele kommentiert er
und da gab es kein keine riesengroße
community mit dem obamas charisma acht
toren die waren zwar echte eingesprungen
beim minister rhein
er warnt vor zuviel hier aufruf an die
schon kostet wird 40 video ja das hat
mich schon total geflasht
und das bedeutet unter bei wem ich bin
bald wesentlich mehr druck
das ist geil also bei mir sagt ich
wollte ich wäre auf meine geschichte ist
lustig erzählte ich die trainerin gemein
manchmal in ställen moderatorin fragen
in memory gerüstet das nicht aufgeladen
dreimal und thomas clarke machte am
allerliebsten nicht kennt wird fragt
bevor er als entdeckt denn beim und zwar
so lustig wir haben ja das schon jahre
dieses projekt texo vorhanden also
langfristig angefangen hatten eine
eigene webseite und dann sind wir 2009
in der amber ende september auf ihn
zugegangen uns alle sachen geht nicht
auf nicht um das ganz ruhig
verschlimmert und spricht und dann ein
paar videos hochgeladen arbeiten bevor
wir richtig starten wollten
und dann haben wir am freitag also
vorher nicht wieder so geladen am 28
september 2009 ein video hochgeladen
im interview mit bushido zum thema reden
will
und das ging sofort durch die decke wir
waren sofort auf der startseite und war
sofort der meisten geklickte kanal an
dem wochenende rund überhaupt erinnert
dieser eine von jetzt auf gleich was ist
das quasi so komplett aus den latschen
ja aber das ist aber auch was gefährlich
ist wenn ich zum beispiel kombi mit
jemand machte gleich jetzt zehn agenten
und ich machte mit dem engine und auf
einmal 2.000 3.000 er weiß ja nicht wie
damit umgehen das ist das monat video
das werden wohl wesentlich höherer
verantwortung hat also das ist es ist
hart also das ist anstrengend
konfrontiert ein plötzlicher nicht etwas
aber es ist so unglaublich ich habe
damals noch die kommentare wurden gemäss
unglaublich unglaublich das ist
natürlich unglaublich ich habe mich auch
riesig freue mich jetzt mehr über die
flügel kommen da wo bei mir genauso von
0 kommentare es war vernünftig wobei
einer echten diesmal gibt es
verschiedene trends es gibt also unter
den kommentatoren gibt es soeben den
trend weiter an seiner mütze postens
gibt aber auch trennt sich wirklich
ernsthafte diskussion zu liefern
also manchmal mich tolle diskussionen
unter videos und manchmal ist es
wirklich total maria punkt aber
unterbrochen wie ersten kommentaren
steht genau das ist dass die ersten
ernten
da hilft nicht dass erster kommentar
nein da herzlich der ist gar nicht so
dann haben wir hier sehr kranken buch
design wer ist das okay aber hier big 19
690 dann ist er oder die wohnung muss
man sagen hier besitzen das also ersten
commander kicker ich bin ein youtube ich
mache kommentierte videospiel videos die
ich versuche im hals tipps tricks und
tipps und humor zu kommentieren
binder mit ein wenig erfolgreich und es
macht einfach nur spaß und macht das
ganze auch beruflich unter dem namen
kleiner krieger
ich sage aber immer heute ist ihr seid
im internet es gibt google ein super
super jana klinge ein natürlich frage
stellt richtet jetzt auch immer okay du
bist gnädig doch ich finde dass nämlich
der könnte google ja das ist aber nicht
so einfach im internet eine frage wer
ist das diese fahne zu sehen ist
eigentlich internet
das ist
leute und okay jetzt kann man sagen
männer kriegen unterstützt diese frau
hat es nie aber es ist einfach ein
möglichkeitsraum er stellt die folge
möchte sieger am programm für mehr gut
da kommt man jetzt lange diskutieren
genau deshalb wieder zurück ich fange
nicht im hauptfeld der diese frage wenn
im internet ist wenn er jetzt fernsehen
gucken würde damit die mails können ich
bin ich versteh ich keine so mache ich
stelle gegen zeuge wir wissen was wirst
du grad noch design genau wer etwas
hörte mit 996 was wirst du für mich
eigentlich alles also er wird kein
faible für bestimmten bestimmten bereich
also ich bin ich einer der ein
komplettes album what aus einem album
gefallen wir zwei drei lieder und die
andern muss ein mehr nicht ich war
eigentlich als aus der volksmusik und
für schlager vorschlag aber das recht
das ist ja ich hatte mal michael wendler
und damit akzeptiere nicht dass auch so
an mir vorbeigegangen genauso auch hier
der schlager also aber wenn man da doch
nicht ich glaube halt jeder hat schon
mal zum inventar oder michael wendler
die klick lösung das ist ja das essen
auf die fußballstadion primitive gesänge
einfach die ganze mit zwei prominenten
publikum genau so was haben wir noch
commander woher hast du deinen
einzigartigen humor deine und eine
riesige ausstrahlung war das schon immer
so oder was du auch schon mal schüchtern
in deinem leben fragt german top
gameplay eine riesige ausstrahlung also
das will erst mal sagen dankeschön dafür
sehe ich selber nicht so mein
einzigartigen [ __ ]
es ist einfach sich aber viel meinen
freunden zu verdanken muss ehrlich sagen
war so klar an die freunde kriegen
aufgewandt und wenn man sich dann
untereinander ein bisschen fällig wenn
mann und ich bin auch jemand auch wie
ich jetzt hier sitze ich sie zu offen zu
euch das war eine aktion die sich jetzt
vor seiner kamera nach dem motto ja
keine angriffsfläche erhalt der ok so
wenn ich jetzt so sitzen
das bringt viele so genau
also so wie ja ich bin so wie ich bin
und ihr könnt mich nicht weil ich so zu
finden
gut sehr gut wir sind
was also aus twitter kommt von pfarrer
kopfkino die frage welche youtuber guckt
krieger die keine letztlich soll ein
kopfkino geiler welche videos gucke ich
habe jetzt zum beispiel von wollt ihr
den song nicht mehr den shop von dir
auch ziemlich cool was was ich gucke
einfach mal so gemütlich mal durch ich
habe eigentlich viele videos anschauen
jetzt aber feste bereiche also feste
kanäle
ich gucke einfach viel ist so gemütlich
einfach durch also keine festen youtube
muss mich verhalten genau
ok ok kannst du mir sagen was du von
apple heißt fragt mehr eckig hier die
frage kommt wahrscheinlich von samsung
handy gesehen hat ich muss sagen ich
finde dieses ganze apple du gewöhnst ist
eine marke wie das am besten jetzt
beschreiben wenn eine autohersteller
so fungieren würde die apple würde der
komplett boykottiert werden meiner
meinung nach einfach gesagt okay wir
nehmen komplett andere reifen andere
schrauben komplett anderes fahrwerk wir
haben anstatt vier reifen haben wir fünf
reifen am auto
wir haben komplett anderes radiomann
sitz komplett anders man guckt anders
was weiß ich alles und ich glaube so was
mit multiple der verteilt damit erfolg
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen um rändern
her soll apple bei st
ich würde es mal probieren aber ich
werde definitiv glaube ich bei
bewusstsein
also ich kenne es von also ich habe mein
kollege der arbeitnehmer ein bild ist
sehr froh hier ist alles ist als durch
gemerkt
elemente einfach vom tisch
genau wir sind ein bisschen defizit
genau
also ich bin hier der gewinn also wir
haben ich habe also zwei beispiel es
gibt ein kollege der hatte auch lara mit
windows und dann muss deren video
irgendwie drehen schneiden 40 stunden
geändert ich bin der satz ich will jetzt
sofort weg und fallen und danach dann so
ich hab das jetzt gemacht dann als eine
minute dauert das ist halt die zeit
das ist für mich oder wenn sie im winter
sogar für mich eine option würde wenn
ford für mich zu komplizieren ist also
fand man muss sie dran arbeiten ins neue
jahr ziehen haben wir ja noch nicht aber
super ich hatte sie dann machst du schon
mit video sehen kann station ich bin
erst wir haben gerade das obwohl dann
irgendwas gemacht
doch dort rat und wieder ja noch gar
nicht
aber es ist leicht ok also wenn ich denn
auch - unter also aus oliven das was ich
tue apple sage es ist das glaube ich und
bitte deshalb mit autos zu tun
es ist heute die billigste art als
staates sind wohl zu kriegen ein aspekt
ist auch ein statussymbol und sollte die
auch leute können sich keine autos mehr
leisten und sind neuwagen
aber mal ganz ehrlich findest du es ein
statussymbol
guck doch mal aus wie viele leute mit
diesem ding und das ist ein problem aber
wie viele lachen ist so die münchner
zwischen affen und lappen bestimmt das
iphone aber damals und jetzt hat jeder
das ist kommerz ist es ist ja auch
manche den beschweren sich auch ja kein
kann sd-karten sorgten die bau dass er
gemeint denn gehen davon aus das ist
eine mutige und wer das ist auch ein
ende ja doch und weil dies nicht
auf ihren videos kompatiblen bolt macht
bis sie im fernsehbereich was einstein
das problem ist aber ich hab mich da
muss er wieder sagen samsung smart tv
hast du mal versucht dann er kann zudem
ich wollte mich damals für maxdome
anmelden ich hab's dann trat sofort das
ist kann nicht mal sein
das ist mit dieser katholik evelyn du
kommst da nicht dran
deine buchstaben und zahlen ich bin
sogar samt braucht dies aber kann man ja
das ist ja mal ein programm i denn so
eine doofe läuft wunderbar ersten
dagegen wenn ich dich wird das eben eine
art und zack kann ich das eigentlich
ich bin und hier mit dem neuen mac os x
lion ist es einer leidenschaft als zehn
nachbeben
da kannst du sofort auf den fernseher
streamen was du auf einem laptop assist
ohne irgendwas keine konfiguration ein
fachblatt ja aber irgendwohin zu sein
und möchte gern dass reichtum macs so
funktioniert weil nirgendwo eine
komponente da reinkommen diese nicht
vorher abgesegnet haben tja da hab ich
ja sagen was in zentren max als sie in
der trotzdem sagt hinterher gesagt
endlich oder der erste hersteller der
unsere spezifikationen zu 100% arabiya
unter dass ein anderes problem
wir sind super die frösche trotzdem
nicht ich würde jetzt muss er hier so
vorstellen wenn du jetzt eine firma und
jetzt auf deutsch schnitt kommt der
lüfter will yvonne microsoft über das
wäre ein traum wie alt sie ist nur da
ist schon der erste punkt ich würde
microsoft in kürze vorverkauf so wird
apple sofort verkaufen sehr gute denn
der winter spaß machen sagt die
produktentwicklung zu ihren spaß ich
kein bock auf das hat viel zu viel
stress
wir haben wir haben auch stress das gut
aufstellt ich glaube dass presley am
schluss war der produktvorstellung ist
und ein tolles einfallen dass das ist
dann dieses amiga habilitation ich finde
das kann ich habe kesselhauses pause war
der sound effekte für die ersten star
trek filme gemacht und er hat ein geiles
doch wer hat die kreis sind wir das
erste plug in für photoshop mit dem
bildeffekte magna gaz kreis borken kreis
power tools unglaublich schnell liefen
und wird den betrag per telefon drin
viel aufwendiger nie schon auf mac des
verdachtes senken fans oft so dass
windräder muss extra muss im amt konnte
diese von dem habe ich eine präsentation
hier in deutschland gesehen und er hat
das lied just an flächen einfach
oktober und zig und gucken sie mal hier
ich fand das toll ich bin diese
amerikanische art unglaublich es kann
kein deutscher ich finde noch nicht
äußern
darin fordert menschen ich krieg auf
dieses army wir sind hier noch eine
neues und real
das ist um dieses problem gewesen doch
das ist er immer glatt dass man das ist
ein hochwertiges gesehen ist die seite
und hierbei sind neuen unterliege
zuschauer einschalten sollen unternehmen
zwei welten aufeinander
also das ist sowieso apple versus pcs zu
empfehlen auch pcs und seiner mac pc eee
pc mit dem tod rettet uns alle das ist
wahr
darauf können wir uns einigen ok dann
halt mal die apple frage mal ausführlich
diskutiert und
hey commander als sm double you to und
encoder black ops als mw2 oder black ops
ist wann wird eigentlich einen
englischen lenkt ausgesprochen dann
heißt es wow mann heißt es darin
für die u bahn 123 kraft 2 wird sicher
noch scheiße ja auch in starcraft wir
brauchen ja dieses workshops muschel
sein okay so und jain w2a warfare 2
warum nicht mal woche drauf geschissen
kommt drauf an europa zweibrücken
fliegerclubs wasserproblem und ab und zu
mit der verbindung ich würde eher sagen
black ops nicht mehr angefochten wird ck
ist du gedacht so erfolgreich zu werden
das hatten wir schon mal
das war übrigens vielen dank an website
for you so frage 6 fangen wir mal wieder
nach dem musik hat man ja schon
donnerstalk vielen dank trotzdem
commander krieger wie wär's mal mit
einem fifa lp kann sich gar nicht
vorstellen dass das kommt ps ich habe
eine dauerkarte bei nürnberg fragt hans
rill 0 runs arbeit habe ich jetzt
getroffen heute gleich mit dabei war
super beziehungstat ian duffy verletzte
ich werde auf jeden fall was im bereich
ultimate team macht mir das spaß macht
ansonsten gab heute und letzte gegensatz
habe ich gespielt
bitte jetzt auf seiner krieger der ckt
clever pkw dieses aus wie lange willst
du noch auf youtube seines seine mir
spaß macht okay gut übrigens die
zuschauerzahlen gehen hier langsam und
stetig nach oben und wir sind bei der
nächste frage die lautet was ist dein
lieblings spiel fragte raymond de 790
flieger probieren
wo kannst du worauf ich halt
oberflächlich ich grinse ja ich kann
nicht lediglich ein gutes da besitzt
immer die kickers dann grimma das stimmt
übrigens im neuen video von tt dass ich
vom nächste woche weiter raus kommt sehr
lustig ihr werdet nicht glaubt von wenig
niedergeschlagen wäre hätte sich danach
aber einfach personen erst klebt ein
bisschen komisch absolut ja aber wenn du
wenn du die ganze zeit so die frage was
macht doch mal zeit schon ein prophet
ist keine weitere taten an ist um
abgewöhnen grenzen aber ansonsten mein
lieblingsspieler von so zu zocken jetzt
ist weiter beruhigen reiche erben und
genau dort spielten okay das kommt jetzt
auch wir haben es geschafft dass jetzt
für pc aus das war bisher nur für die
xbox mögen dann haben wir mal so
videomaterial das unterschreiben wird
und jetzt von anfang 2013 auf 15
hattest du ein vorbild als du bei
youtube angefangen hast fragt das sirius
lpd erhoben damals um pro bild docter
kaputten müssen von ich kenne ich kenne
ich kenne mich in der szene hat am
anfang viel dokumentiert auch dieses
jetzt geht dahin er ist für mich quasi
der documenta sender unter den
kommentator okay das heißt er
kommentiert spiele nach aber das ganze
auf einem level was schon jan open
format hat ein video gemacht
ein erfahrungsbericht 100 stunden
betreibt die große zusammenfassung der
wohnt auf der seite unter präsentiert
weil das video so genial war das steckt
so viel arbeiten und das für mich so ein
bisschen der documenta auf youtube im
bereich
wobei ich kann nur sagen aus dem
fernsehen dokumentarfilm lohnen sich
nicht mag sich den arbeit viel ehre
das problem ist er braucht halt sehr
viel zeit dafür zu bearbeiten und daher
ist der video und sehr gering es gab
jetzt vor wonach eine video vor sieben
monaten im video
das ist jedenfalls dann wird man dann
nicht von in turin
so jetzt fragt ribery 7x hast du schon
mal besoffen gezockt sicherlich dass ich
mich kommt nur fünf mitarbeiter die
fresse reaktionen lassen nach 100 m
vorlauf gut vorbild hat man jetzt hier
schon acea wie bist du aus dass auf das
baw tisch gekommen fragt new gameplay
zerstört hat also irgendwie sowas ja und
es hat sich eingebürgert
es ist wie beim mehrere sensationelles
kommt irgendwie weiß ich ich dachte da
niemand gerne
mir macht es auch so extrem auf der
wieder auf
sensationell egal wo sensationell
okay dachte ich schon nach der ersten
woche dokument ok ok die sensationell
sensationell gut damit haben diese mails
durch benni da kommt wieder nix ich
liebe mich das ist ja das so da kommt
für de
was wollte ich dazu sagen und das
schlimme ist ja so oder so was ist immer
technik und schwere technik macht's
möglich
kein schlechtes deutsch aber manchmal
ist sicher schon über dürfen
zurückgegangen am freitagabend ist von
zu arbeiten müssen wir haben diesmal die
fünf toll das projekt zu machen
das ist bei den praktikanten so lieber
und jens toll spaß genau macht spaß so
siehst du dich als promi fragt krieger
des friedens ich sehe mich nicht als
problem ganz normaler mensch so wie ich
bin
ab bestimmten kann er sich da mal das
ist ja eigentlich db niveau ist eine
grenze
ich fasse ich eben immer und ich sehe
mich sony hat ob ich mache das aus spaß
wenn ihr autogramm haben wollte ok ich
fühle mich jetzt nicht dazu buchen von
eur glaube ich finde mich nicht jetzt
dass man sich total mega attraktiv seien
müsste unbedingt von der nasa das ist
alles euro ihr findet es also gut was
sagst du zu minecraft bergwinkel master
sieben hsv
ich habe selber mal gespielt ich fand es
auch gar nicht mal so schlecht hat mir
dann meine eigene welt aufgebaut und
dadurch zerstört wird mit 80 meter ja
ungefähr genauso
ich hatte so richtig gern regenwalds im
ries brust raus und am besten wie die
luft gejagt weil sie ist alles
abgebrannt wir ausarbeiten
bist du zufrieden mit deinem leben fragt
4 production 100 wenn ich's nicht erhöht
was ändern ok also ich muss eigentlich
finde ich habe ihn jeder mensch hat die
möglichkeit etwas zu ändern was ihm
nicht gefällt
und egal was es ist man muss nur auf gut
deutsch die eier in der hose haben ist
zu versuchen es zu warm und wenn man das
meistens macht trägt man dadurch erst
mal sagen und man schafft es meistens
auch dass zunehmend genieße einfach nur
genießen gehen oder was er macht macht
was draus
also ich hab ja tot wenn du irgendwann
nach oben von der himmel
türen dann bin ich da sein und bis 18
ok ich hab' mir hab alles erledigt was
ich machen wollte ich hab spaß gab hilft
hier denke ich auch wenn man jetzt auf
möchte man muss eigentlich jeden tag
sterben können wir jeden tag sterben
dann wird man auch im richtigen leben
man kann das ziel nicht erreicht aber
man sollte keine zigarette genießen oder
seid wirklich noch oder zu trinken ist
auch glaube ich für euch liebe zuschauer
das ist wirklich das leidenschaft ist
das allerwichtigste
wobei man muss dann am anfang wo ihr
profil jetzt von euch sind ist die
schulzeit und in dieser zeit trägt ihr
die möglichkeiten der linie später
ausbauen wird
das heißt wir mit der für die schule
dlrg mehr damit agiert bza und jetzt so
einfach wenn du ihr spiel ja und man
kann ja auch eine schule für was leiden
schafft es kann ja kunst seines kann
geschichte sein man sollte versuchen
dafür irgendetwas denn leidenschaft ich
habe jetzt ein ölscheich war vorgestern
in dem das team bei kollegen und da
kamen dann die frage auf das gekämpft
was einen beruf ausüben
ich sehe eher streep wird bis nun
erzählt anja erst 19 jahre alt hat
hauptschule jetzt gerade abgeschlossen
er findet aber nichts so habe ich kurz
guckt wo herr tom dollar
basf hat nach ausbildung besucht zum
ersten leuten als stoppen fragte anpackt
und wir auch gar nicht ist aber auch
hier haben am ersten neun ausbildung vor
dem essen bei opfern zur verfügung
und die haben am dritten leuten das
ganze eben noch mal kritisiert das heißt
da die anzeigen auch jedes die hat noch
kein gehen
mach dich in schale nördlichen schaden
wenn deine aufrührer den unterlagen mit
und gehen dahin und sagten wir jetzt den
job haben und sagt du hast das gesehen
warum du darüber ob man es irgendwo ein
bisschen zu lassen bessere chance
nochmal arsch hochkriegen und das
nachweislich ja das ist das hat auch was
mit hast du gesagt hat selbstvertrauen
das zu tun was man wirklich aber da ist
auch dass das risiko bei einem
praktikanten dass du kannst nun in
glückslos haben
oder du kannst du nachher haben gesagt
nur durch
die arbeit und nicht ganz anders
vorstellen wobei das wie hast du die
arbeit hier vorgestellte als praktikant
wie es jetzt ist ich mal selber schnell
zwei jahren youtube-videos und ich
wusste genau was auf mich zukommt auch
in dem in dem fenster
also hält sein könnten was soll sich das
er dass er christoph manchmal kommt ja
also muss ich weiter schon mal lief bis
80 jährige wurde jetzt viele kollegen
was die häuser ziehen würdest und der
schönen kannte uns mit ziel sitzen zwei
alten säcken die ihr von lanken
fingerring und irgendwelche fragen
schicken
also ich muss sagen christoph hat mir
gesagt ich arbeiten muss und ich habe
gesagt dass man drei stunden länger sind
dann ist es so ich hab ich habe vorher
mein studium gemacht
wer bis jetzt ich bin 24 natürlich jetzt
und ich gedacht ich hätte jetzt will ich
über eine schule ich habe mein studium
fertig gemacht wenn ich dann können
kommen und ich habe gesagt ich mache
jetzt hier nochmal feuerwaffen bei
youtube jetzt stehen 20 stunden am tag
und ich freue mich es macht spaß
ok ich hab' youtube genauso wir aber
genau das ist das wichtige ist die
landschaft einpendeln
auch die motivation dahinter noch zu
haben
es gibt viele leute die sagen ja ich
habe die motivation und ich kann endlich
den commander träger sitzen dort sitzen
deutschland sind seine ersten tag ist
super aufgeregt zweiter tag auch noch
kollegen nach einer woche sind noch viel
arbeiten das ist die angst die ich hätte
weil wenn nicht mehr verkehren ruhen
würde der krieg der götter aufgabe weil
wir soll heimat haben davon also einfach
sich in die eier grundsätzlich ja und
dann hat die gefahr hin dass wieder
viele stars aber er sehe ich glaube
erstens man merkt dass die kräfte
nachließen gespräch nicht so viele
ich glaube insgesamt waren es vielleicht
fünf ok also wir haben also was nicht
geht also du merkst ja ganz schnell auf
einer fan ist oder wenn du fan bist das
geht nicht
es geht einfach nicht weil
das steht im vordergrund und es dur ist
wenn du ein ich dachte es beim videodreh
auf soja ich möchte einmal begegnet hat
das wird auch passieren wenn du ein
praktikum macht aber wenn du die
begegnung in den vordergrund stellt
sagen hast du kein praktikum nur noch
dann funktioniert das alles nicht du
wirst den begegnen und zwar wenn du
wirklich ein haus auf eine friedlichere
und spannendere aber das kannst du nur
haben wenn du spaß seine arbeit hatte
und an dem markt machen bei genesis
jetzt so wir haben uns auch vor sehr
intensiv unterhalten und sortieren eines
woher macht ihr ein eigenes projekt also
dann kommt ein neuer youtube-kanal raus
mit was wo wir glauben das ist
einschlagen wird wie eine bombe und
sensationell genau und das ist auch das
nicht dass man den leuten was zu tun
würden dass sie am ende denken das ist
muss ja auch da wollen wir auch gucken
dass ich festgestellt habe
und das habe ich auch haben ja schon mal
ausgesprochen aufgrund des wahnsinns auf
wandelt ich habe so vernachlässigt
persönlich vor der kamera zu sein also
einfach mal die kamera was du machst
beim autofahrer sonst was und das muss
ich unbedingt intensivieren und da
wollen wir auch hier alles ist auch noch
dabei die beiden team damit man mehr
mitbekommt die das ist weil es ist schon
so dick so hat sonst so diesen charakter
von fernsehsendungen auf youtube und das
passt überhaupt nicht und mustert
youtube ist islamisierung auf und das
muss ich ganz wichtig und wenn man das
zu sehr vernachlässigt das war im
letzten halbjahr viel zu tun
doch manchmal an der punkt wenn du
aufhörst eine pause machen aber es macht
dann sehen was und wir haben weitere
fragen von bismarck o2 uk hat dir dein
hobby jemals geschadet
also nicht beruflich von wegen der gamer
nicht hauptberuflich ist nicht
intellektuell nach dem motto fürs gaming
markt blöd größer und so weiter
intelligent ab dadurch dass die ganzen
spaß daran siehst du die ganzen fehler
fällt das auch du weißt erstmal wirklich
ist und vor allen dingen dadurch dass
man sich jedes mal neu überlegen muss
das geht natürlich thema die rate mal
einfach mal so hämmerle dazu muss bei
uns dann gibt es geld muss man sich ein
bisschen formieren das feld dann schaut
so was interessiert euch das ist
vielleicht überhaupt jemals interessiert
mir gar nicht dann muss man doch immer
ein bisschen recherchiert ein bisschen
lachen und erfährt dann doch mal ganz
interessante dinge und kann so seinen
horizont erweitern nicht kommentieren ja
und das let's play com
also geben kann auch natürliche holz
aber wurde das kommentiert kommentiertes
gegenwärtige anlagen oder auch nicht so
egal was man macht ich denke man hat
auch den meisten sind irgendwo muss egal
was man ja außerdem als eine idee
generell meine liebe tante may sagt wenn
irgendwas nicht so ganz toll lief
wer weiß wofür es gut ist sollte man
zieht aus allen aus allem was in meinem
leben passiert auch was position auf die
lage schlimmes ist man zieht immer auch
was positives
weiter da waren wir nicht durch anita
xbox oder ps3 fragt theo 444 nur die
meisten erfolge zocken
musicstar nicht also mal verprügelt
worden bist oder total abgelöst hat in
der klausur oder lehrerinnen oder
nämlich vernachlässigt kein schimpfen
scheiße gebaut aber alle aber ich hab'
war witzig geschulten keller gegangen
ziemlich lang ist so ein schlauch im
keller
wir haben uns ja schon als ich an die
eine ecke gestellt der andere an die
andere nicht ausgemacht aufeinander zu
kaufen irgendwann durch mobile ort uns
gegenseitig ein gespräch heraus wie
schneemänner dann super sorgen am
brennen bis zum geht immer wieder
beschworen das ist schon schön
die hausordnung per hand abschreiben
zehnmal mittag maria war dazu nicht auf
drei seiten schön areal 10
das hört sich ein bisschen schutz wenn
du dich in einem wort beschreiben müsste
es welches wort wäre das fragt
shooting-star flash jetzt bist du dann
es gibt mehr als man kann sich schwer
mit einem einzigen wort beschreiben
wir sind für mich viele faktoren die
hier ein fall humor offenheit
ehrlichkeit der so vieler faktoren die
für mich damit ein fließt also
beeindruckt so wieder überwinden
nächsten geboren
man beschreibt sich am meistens selbst
positiv was ist an die schon am meisten
kritisiert worden
vom aussehen her gehen halt die meisten
drauf aber das ist irgendwie bei den
kleinen das irgendwie so ergeben dass
man hätte da drauf ziel musste als erste
sichtbar das heißt die ansicht oder
sagen sie sich traut sich das aber unter
diese behauptung sei und was tatsächlich
alles geschlechterfragen ich dann gucken
wir mal wenn die fed ist auch so aber er
sagt das fühlt sich keiner traum wahr
dafür ist der und dafür ist vielleicht
noch die hemmschwelle der respekt zurück
das finde ich auch gut ist auch noch
kunden holen denkt momentan scheint aber
das ist halt was was offensichtlich ist
was eventuell meine schwäche wäre die
ebene schule und sehen alles klar
ich beleidige jetzt mal zehn meiner
klassenkameraden da sind zwei audick
weil so ein blödes bonn zwei
dunkelhaarig und was für sich und er
will alle windows und den winkel springt
halt darauf an alcon fett ist da merkte
okay bin ich ihnen ja damit beschimpfe
da kommt der hand und er zeigt mir eine
reaktion das meiste was er noch der
harmloseste reaktion nach dem motto du
bist mein ich bin für doom ist hof hat
er seine reaktion die ihn in einer
gewissen weise befriedigt und da geht ja
immer weiter im coffee weitergehen kann
ich das einfach schon gar nicht davor
mehr weil ich sage selber ich bin fit
fühle mich wohl so gut
würdest du für deine freundin mit
youtube aufhören fragt fragt frech mango
so gesehen muss ich natürlich sagen nein
weil youtube ist mein job
youtube macht mir spaß das sind zwei
faktoren die sie erst mal mit dem
argument erst mal absteigt muss und
warum sollte meine freundin mir sagen
dass ich aufhören soll damit sie mehr
zeit hat oder so also dass das
wahrscheinlich der faktor und wenn sie
mich glücklich sony würde wie ich bin da
muss youtube akzeptieren gehört zu mir
und zwar ziemlich auch gelacht und gut
und johannes schaal auf twitter fragt
frager commander krieger machst du noch
deine karriere auf youtube ich weiß noch
nicht ob ich das weitermache es ist das
problem
ich kenne viele nachrichten von leuten
meiner ersten tipps angenommen haben und
dann sagen
der erfolg kommt jetzt nicht so wie ich
mir vorstelle tc dies wirklich nicht als
leitfaden sehen als wirklicher anleitung
mache so und du wirst genauso
erfolgreich und das funktioniert es hat
ja mit wahnsinnig viel zu tun ich sage
immer erstens ist es natürlich die idee
ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt noch
letzte kanal aufmachen damit überhaupt
nichts zu tun also jetzt einsatz
darunter mit durchstarten ohne ende
chance 1 zu überhaupt nicht du musst nur
ne geile idee ja es muss ja gute
musikalische idee zum beispiel ist
gestern vorgestern youtuber gefunden
werden kommentiert macht wo der video da
redet ok als anzocken mit jutta und es
ist an sich ich hing da ich habe mich
kaputt gedacht war das auch wirklich
sehr gut
natürlich willst du mit dieser idee
kannst du nicht jetzt 2000 elementen
machen weiß dass das eine gesellschaft
bereits nach dem dritten viertel
da muss mehr kommen man muss ja etwas
was nicht arbeite und das kann ja auch
arbeiten aber es war schon mal ein
interessanter einstieg der hatte damals
als ich ihn gesehen aber das erste mal
dort wird zu den abonnenten
ich habe ihn und auch wie jemand der
schon 400 bis jetzt natürlich kein
risiko können aber es ist schon ein
großer sprung fürchten
und das gibt auch neue energie was neues
machen
also das war das eine idee ist die idee
sein diesen papieren sympathie
da muss man nachbarn können sollte gar
nicht muss offen sein und muss auch mit
leuten arbeiten und durchhaltevermögen
das glaube ich auch
du musst nur durch strecke mussten ein
leichtes fällt ein dickes fell brauchen
sehr dicken selber man ja also die
ganzen kommentare die gehen auch
teilweise wenn man das alles liest
willich weisheit beim heftigst video wie
viele leute meine mutter beleidigt haben
wo ich auch sagen sollte es ist mir
scheißegal ob er meine mutter beleidigt
ich habe das video für die baltic macht
dies verstanden um die wären dafür mehr
irgendwann mal sehr dankbar sein bzw
werden sich selber dankbar sein dass sie
das gemacht haben und die anderen leute
werden irgendwann sagen hätte ich doch
mal nicht kriege ich genau das gleiche
machen und dann hänge ich dann aber das
mache ich nicht länger für mich man
brauche ein dickes fell und ich glaube
mein garten dickes thema muss ich selber
gut kennen deine stärken seine schwächen
weil es greift ein jahr die leute nehmen
ja die entdecken die sofort die karten
das ist aber überall wo überall damit
konfrontieren sagt doch du bist überall
in deinem leben mit entsprechenden
punkte aber es gibt leute die haben
strategien dagegen entwickelt wie sie
dem aussehen doch studer ja und du hast
auf youtube katzen hat überhaupt nicht
aus dem wege gehen weil dort ständig
immer noch mal zum beispiel basketball
saison geht bin ich merke hier denn wenn
ihn der hat total das problem dass wenn
ich mache da fehlt erfolge auf einem
acht jahre dauernde deutschland direkt
und mache solange das heißt ich habe
seine stärken aus genauso egal wenn ein
anderer schwäche hat also ich kann dir
ein wunderbares beispiel erzählen das
für mich da ist es klassiker von
wahrscheinlich nicht so gut ist
kandidatin bei dsds wird in von der jury
kommt mit lange macht so nach dem motto
kannst dich papa papa vor allem wieder
boden da kommt die zwar ähnlich aus und
sagt eine meinung und das sind schon
tags strategie patienten
ich will sie aber die kamera letzten der
trainer
und dann sagte er ja du sehnst als wenn
eine katze vergewaltigt
ich bin super das hat meine mama mir
gemacht
sorry aber da muss man wirklich sein
wird die mutter geschlagen aber dass es
gibt da gibt es unendlich viele leute
sich das ist total das ist ja keine
strategie und hab ich finde ich glaube
man kann sich selber nicht richtig
einschätzen
einzelfahrten sich subjektiv was man
sagt es ist schwieriger wird muss
natürlich das musst du versuchen aber du
wirst nie erreichen nur es gibt
wahnsinnig viele menschen halt sehr weit
davon entfernt die auf youtube sind wenn
sie groß scheint ja definitiver wenn ich
authentisch
damit wäre das geklärt bei dir aus dem
cad cam cae kartnig südafrika-ticket
okay sein peinlichstes erlebnis größe
sany cologna 86 ich hatte meine
erlebnisse ich bin sogar cool was heißt
du ich bin zwar auch ein kleiner
tollpatsch und tierfellen das immer so
aber jetzt so ein richtig geiles
erlebnis wo ich mich so geschämt habe
finde
würdest du gerne mit julians blog
diskutieren thema egal fragt vfl 1848 2
ich halte ihn für einen sehr
intelligenten und warum ich glaube jeder
hat von uns über dem ausruhen
aber er ist ja ein bisschen dieser arten
schottet ja das ist wohl wahr ist kann
ich bei dir die ausbildung zum kommando
machen fragt michael private events über
gelegentlich machen
ok-chef rentiere bei mir gibt es
definitiv noch keine ausbildungsstelle
und eine außenstelle
ok es sowieso trägst du eine brille
keine kontakte rationierung raymond de 7
und zwar so sehe ich wirklich noch
schlimmer aus bernhard brehl super kann
sein gesicht damit ein bisschen
verstecken
also ganz ehrlich nicht gewesen ich
hatte kontakt in sich ohne stern hast du
sie okay bei der brille nicht wenn ich
billige die seite dann wird ihre am ende
sogar vorstellen mit welcher seine anti
krebs auge und bei mir geht als bereiche
kontakt ermöglicht hast es wie im ruhm
zu erhöhen
ich habe solche einrichtung ist gar
nicht in einer stunde ist alles rot und
ich hatte noch formstabil so heldt
weiter
doch da bisher nicht ich mag keine
fremdkörper man wie viel geld hast du
dein gesamtes gaming equipment
ausgegeben sprich micro computer
bildschirme und so weiter fakt breiter
weiter freitag bestimmt bis 6000 meter
das ist ein ordentlicher pc zum rendern
und müssen schon mal so manche 2 2000
ungefähr haben dann habe ich jetzt bei
mir 339 fernsehen zu bestehen
als monitor nutze die ganzen konsolen
die aufnahmegeräte den ganzen headsets
gut was sind deine lieblings youtuber
fragt maurus hater youtuber die mich
unterhalte also gibt jetzt kein festival
den gibt er muss dort fuster 2
tatsächlich im kloster oder toaster
schuster 2
sehr witzig finde wir kommentieren ich
auch nicht mit ihnen super verstehe aber
ansonsten gibt jetzt kein wahrsager den
verfolge ich von dort konzert von ok
wird also deine empfehlung geht in
richtung post gut passage ist muss ich
ja ich kenne keinen nachschub
jetzt kommt wieder was ich mag
mal gucken
ja ok 13 mein namens name ist fragt wie
hoch würdest du dich auf youtube
einschätzen
man kann es auch im kanal aufsehen
das macht also ungefähr vielleicht auch
so aber mehr nicht gut ich würde
wirklich informativ drücke ich würde
sagen wir kommen wir jetzt haben wir
nämlich schon 20 und 20 ich finde 90
minuten ist und länger eigentlich wir
können jetzt langsam in den endspurt
kommen weil ich glaube dass aber durch
im vorfeld auch besprochen erweckt er
schloss soll das wohl heißen und 87 tk
wie lange bist du jetzt schon rauchfrei
aber ich will nicht mehr frei ist es ja
ich habe hier ein bisschen vorbereitet
ok nach jetziger alte sie ziemlich
monströser aus das teil ist es auch ich
bin ja schon so unter den den elite
dampfern das sind ja sowieso japanologen
ersten schritt erhält mehrere tage und
und schaltet man an und trauer
kannst du machen kann nicht vormachen
aber ich bin dieses display man sie
nämlich 1000 zahlen oder so drauf
rezession aber jetzt auftritt beleuchtet
falsche objekt ich muss trotzdem sagen
es ist darum viele leute es ist doch
eine shisha ersatz sein
in dem ding ist trotzdem also hier in
dieser flüssigkeit in dieser flüssigkeit
gehe da seht es trotzdem nikotin ist
trotzdem stetig also es ist nicht so
schädlich wie der normale kippe
beziehungsweise ist noch nicht erwiesen
worden
ich merke aber ich kriege besser luft
ich kann bei verbänden ich kann deshalb
richtig kann besser schmecken
das ist für mich wohl als uni sparen
noch geld wenn die nicht rauchen sollten
damit werde ich es an weil auch
nur scheiße wie sie dort auch nochmals
nicht wann ich kann mich zigaretten auch
überhaupt und ich gehe da nicht was
ich bin ja zu jedem experiment immer
gern der wahl soll ich okay stieg die
volle dosis vielen dank meine damen und
herren nicht also jetzt zum abschluss
die volle dosis mitten ins gesicht und
jetzt jetzt jetzt zeigt sich ist es
wirklich also erstmal richtig gut sogar
normalerweise hätte ich jetzt kein
lachen sondern einmal so es ist das was
ich aus reiner wasserdampf das heißt für
dich schon er schädigt das heißt auch
hier deutlich an so habe ich nicht
verklagen nach wie vor hier
du brauchst auch gar nichts wussten ja
schauspieler so es ist muss nur sein die
frage kann auch richtig weil ich gab
ihnen schon bemerkt haben muss wieder
mal brauchst du deinen seinen stoff es
ist eine sucht trotzdem lang also es ist
jetzt nicht irgendwie dass diese sucht
jetzt damit befriedet ist ich habe meine
sucht man gedanklich bin jetzt ob es ist
genau so manche leute die auf hört man
rauchen fressen
sagenhaft viel lakritze und wären dann
halt sie so eine tonne jetzt schon mal
vor ich würde meine suche auf der kippe
umlage das ist schon in ordnung erstmal
sohn vielleicht kann man das dann so um
ich habe auch kein problem dass franck
auch einige kitas in der diskothek oder
so brauchen
schämst du dich nicht dafür warum dort
ich mich schämen
also ich mein verein ist es auch
wirklich witzig ich war mit meiner
freunde der diskutanten club cala ja
gewöhnt und durchaus mit dem weg und da
kommt eine anfreunden
die schmeckten der jetzt bitte passt ja
wenn du denn jetzt christi schmecken der
ist überhaupt fragst du nicht hast du ja
sie kam erst besser sagt und sie als
schränkt mich darauf sie ist sofort
morgen hatte gehen die zitate sind also
ja du hast gar kein problem
mit raum kennen zu lernen der
aschenbecher die man gerade selber
gemerkt ich habe auch schon muss ich
ehrlich gesagt sagen
das verlangt nach einer normalen
zigarette mal wieder wettzumachen wort
um dieses ich hab mir mal zigarette
angezündet nach zwei zügen hat mir
überhaupt nicht geschmeckt wieder
ausgemacht gut ist es brauche ab und zu
nach motto probieren schmeckt scheiße
alles da wohnt ist würdest du den moment
würde ich habe mit 19 angefangen also
wenn auch lächerlich diese nachts schon
zusammengewachsen sind
meine mutter sogar noch bücher
geschickter endlich nicht auch ein
scheiß verlassen haben das habe ich dann
selber angefangen finger tyrann angehen
oder mehrere türsteher als damals
mit einer kippa sondern erzielte zweimal
an das schmeckt sonderlich schlimm stück
zwecke zum einsatz muss dann gebt am 1
also in diesem sinne fangen nicht an zu
kaufen würde ich immer wieder belastbar
sein und man ist nicht unbedingt nicht
cooler und man muss es letztlich
irgendwann nehmen weil die zigaretten
mögliche komplette scheiße sich auch vom
preiswerten also ich denke ich habe
damals angefangen zigarettenmarke bosse
da wir anfangen zu rauchen und jetzt
dabei
ich glaub 6 eur 12 magna wir kennen noch
die mag ich habe auch gedankt für einen
euro 34 ich glaube ich habe noch etwas
für was ich noch irgendein erste kleine
lager 15 34 sitze da muss ich mit einer
meiner oder 99 mal erzähle ich noch
gedacht für 134
ich versuche immer mein alter nicht
veröffentlich nicht ob nächstes jahr
will ich mal
ok dann will ich auch erzählt wie viel
wenn ich mal gemacht haben so teuer
erwarb von werken 12 bei uns auch
hunderte tankstellen oder billigt
tankstelle
die machen alle platt irgendwie also
demnächst über schaffen geschaffen sich
das tanzpaar ihr die ganzen ölkonzern
seite zu starten
ich habe ja folgen
ich hatte früher mal bmw elf liter
furchtbar war auch kaputt hand ohne ende
der kosten also ich nichts gegen bmw
aber meiner war nicht so dann habe ich
mir und das war echt ein segen ein prius
gekauft übrig der fünf meter oder fünf
jahren lag der schnitt für mich
gebraucht hat das heißt die hälfte von
den bmw ich habe ohne in bendern
hochrechnen was spass patienten kaum
nicht einmal notwendig bei 29 liter
höher statt du bist bin ich nie gedacht
oh ne scheiße so das ist doch man sich
29 erweisen was du da ausgibst dafür
habe ich einmal zu fall
so und jetzt kommt man erst jetzt durch
jahr 2000 braucht und jetzt als nächsten
bekomme ich den trust übergehen und das
gerade gesagt dein auto setzt wo ich der
zwei 3200 1100 stellen die laufen auch
viele gibt die laufen richtig gut
eigentlich aber es gibt jetzt ein prius
plug-in und den geschäftsleuten
steckdose und ich bin vorher viel
elektroautos ganzen projektes super und
der 420 kilometer ohne dass du benzin
voraus und das daf reichen schon nicht
auf du sparst wirklich einen riesen teil
der anschaffungskosten straße möglichst
den stromkosten ja nicht trocken ist so
viel billiger ich habe das jahr der
strom kostet 20 cent pro kilowattstunde
und ich glaube du brauchst
beim würden 100 kilometer kosten du
kannst sagen meine tochter braucht
glaube ich 33 kilowattstunden auf wenn
ich nichts ich muss mich mal sehen ob
das realistisch drankommen 123 das als
er verbraucht 15 kilowattstunden auf 100
kilometer die kilowattstunde liegt aber
um die 20 cent zahlt nicht hinter uns
was euro aber ich mache weil ich nicht
ich bin jetzt bei 7 7 liter öl 67 bleibt
habe ich bei meinem sehr okay diese
kraft
du kannst halt muss sie mich sehen aber
trotzdem spaß macht und ich brauche hier
vom bund von meinem wohnort hier in die
stadt gori meter ich habe am büro eine
steckdose
das heißt ich komme mal steckt und muss
16 abwehr haben und da hat keinen
niedrig muss 16 ampere abgesichert sein
sind aber eigentlich meisterstück
bedeutet im büro bei uns hat mal
es gab somit elektroauto tour durch
deutschland haben uns mal stark gemacht
mein gott wie ich stromer dabei wolf ist
roma und da war wirklich ja ich bin noch
da ja unentwegt ist herzlich und da
wirklich die sekte unter sport nach dem
spiel
also es geht doch mit steckdose ist
immer ein bisschen könnte heiss werden
aber ich glaube es ist der ist wirklich
wohl durchdacht konstruieren
das tolle am prius ist noch viel spaß
war sich viele reparaturkosten die
bremsscheiben vorne musste ich nach 120
tausend kilometer zum ersten mal
tauschen die hinten sind jetzt noch
200.000 das ist der wahnsinn und des
bunny last an das getriebe ist total
simpel da ist was dran motor und läuft
ja nicht so hoch drehen aber das wollte
jetzt keine werbung sein
ich wollte nur sagen wie ich vollauf
herhalten elektro um nachdrücklich um an
den dortigen börsen sind mit einigen uns
widerfährt
dass der automarkt mit glück us christen
so oft 15
also bei twitter das mit mir yamaha
setzt auf autos sowie einmal darunter
rhein aus
die 15
ok also demnächst noch mehr zu hören von
commander krieger vor allem aus dem
auspuff oder die alle einen noch befragt
was für projekte anständig klar doch
momentan schon soviel links ist ja ich
will
vielleicht kennen die super um sich
draußen haben und zwar willig nach china
fliegen
ich weiß noch nicht wann genau will dann
nur 200 kikis dann hoch new york durch
die rocky mountains in kanada dann
wieder unter kenny widerruf nach alaska
wieder runter lassen um dann keine wie
nach allee 23
ok und das ist mein großes ziel das zu
machen oder gar nicht wenn dort ein
hammer wenn du dich schon so ein
bisschen ist das gute so ein überland
vermietung
das heißt wo christen hammer aber du
musst du in san francisco abgeben
beispielsweise musste in chicago gehen
oder was weiß ich dann spaß du damit so
viel geld weil die autovermietung
müssten sonst für teuer geld selber
hinterher und reduzieren so dermaßen die
preise und ein christ war was bei sich
im keller so einrichten es
korrekterweise christenheit wirklich für
eine abnormale und der sprit noch in
amerika immer so billig aber das ist
auch stehen leute nun also amerika
tanken ist die umwelt meine ich jetzt so
ganz wo heutzutage klar man soll danach
legen aber ganz ehrlich da gibt es viele
andere baustellen aber ja aber das ist
ein thema da kannst du auch wieder so
wie ich will
ich bin keiner der die chancen ein
man kann auch nicht genau man kann ja
nicht komplett unlust oder nur mit
selbstbeschränkung und cas gemacht auch
wenn wir mit diesem
das ist dass diese aktion zwei
fingerabdrücke es gibt irgendwo eine
seite ich weiß ich irgendwas für zwei
mannheimer hat er genau der wird dann
hätte was weiß ich im bundestag ist das
ein bisschen mal wieder hingefahren die
großen projekte ermöglicht wird hat
gesagt du hast der umwelt so viel
geschadet als friemann bis hin zu sehen
ich finde auch dieses schlechte gewissen
ist einfach genau die falsche art seine
produktion
warum jetzt nicht müller muss ist ja
liebe politiker jetzt hat ihr gefallen
finde ich dafür ja auch wieder anderes
thema also da kann er auch wieder das
auch hatte com politik in europa
religion und politik dass er noch tränen
von den drei teams offen distanziert
ganz einfach weil du kannst es nicht
allen recht machen das ist genauso wie
findest du den youtube was interessiert
euch meine medizin finden und ob ich ihn
finden oder den finden oder zara ihre
muss sich gefallen nicht einfach
und 60 dann fielen dank commander kinder
da geht es um zum ersten mal live
mehr als diesen spaß gemacht hoffe auf
euch auch und ich hoffe die auch super
dann machen wir das mal wieder wenn
wieder ein gast dann auch wirklich live
kommt das war's und ansonsten ist bei
ihm auf jeden fall commander giger